lo que quiere hacer en este vídeo es
explorar la noción de razón y veamos
varios ejemplos que seguramente se han
encontrado en su vida diaria imaginen
que van manejando su auto y quizás vean
que viajan a 60 k p h en donde kph donde
kph significan 60 kilómetros por hora
esto indica que si mantenemos esta
velocidad en una hora recorreremos 60
kilómetros esto sucederá si mantenemos
la razón o tasa actual en este caso
tenemos una medida de la rapidez o
velocidad cuánta distancia recorremos o
cubrimos en una unidad de tiempo y lo
más típico cuando las personas hablan de
tasa o razón es cuánto de algo ocurre en
una unidad de tiempo aunque no tiene que
ser una distancia por unidad de tiempo
podríamos tener una tasa o razón por
hora de la cantidad de dinero que gana
alguien
es decir que ganan 150 pesos la hora
nuevamente aquí hablamos de lo que gana
una persona por unidad de tiempo ya no
hablamos de distancia y aunque las tasas
o razones se ha asociado comúnmente con
cuanto de algo sucede en una unidad de
tiempo kilómetros por hora o metros por
segundo o como en este caso de un sueldo
pesos por hora las razones no siempre
tienen que ver con esto por ejemplo yo
puedo tener un postre que me guste mucho
pero quiero cuidar el número de calorías
que consumo y este postre contiene 200
calorías por porción esto nos dice la
cantidad de calorías en una porción
aunque no nos dice en qué consiste la
porción quizás sea una taza o quizás
sean 100 gramos o algo así por lo que
puedo decir si me como dos porciones voy
a consumir 400 calorías lo mismo ocurre
si digo que trabaje 2 horas entonces
tendré 300 pesos o si conduzco por dos
horas habré
y 220 km una razón nos indica qué tan
rápido puede suceder algo o cuánto de
una cosa ocurre durante una unidad de
otra cosa puedo escribir razones de
manera que se vean muy similares a las
proporciones o fracciones y ambos
conceptos están relacionados
la proporción por ejemplo si tomo los 60
kilómetros por hora también podría decir
que si recorrí 60 kilómetros en una hora
su proporción de kilómetros a horas
proporción de kilómetros
a horas
sería 60 a 1 o quizás 120 a 2 no algo
así pero esto se reduce a 60 aún no las
proporciones las encontramos de esta
manera o aquí podemos expresarla como 60
sobre 1 incluso a veces las pueden
encontrar expresadas así 60 kilómetros
60 kilómetros por una hora
y en esta forma luce muy parecido a un
caso especial de las proporciones que se
llama razón o razones en donde en lugar
de escribir 60 kilómetros por hora no
escribimos 60 kilómetros
por ahora ambas son ideas muy
relacionadas si encontramos la
proporción entre calorías y porciones
podremos expresarla como una razón y
viceversa porque nos interesan las tasas
o razones bueno pensando en cosas como
la velocidad si las razones sería
difícil cuantificar qué tan rápido
suceden las cosas sin razones estaríamos
en un mundo en el que veríamos yo viajo
más rápido que tú o ella va más rápido
que yo pero no podríamos cuantificar que
tanto más rápido van en cambio con las
razones podemos decir hoy esa persona
corrió 100 metros en 10 segundos por lo
que va a 10 metros por segundo podemos
cuantificar exactamente qué tan rápido
sucede esto la razón o la tasa de lo que
está sucediendo aquí en lugar de decir
bueno dos de estas cosas me van a
engordar más que dos de estas otras
cosas y hacer estas comparaciones
relativas con las razones podemos
cuantificar las cosas con exactitud
las razones estudian mucho en
matemáticas porque son esenciales en el
álgebra cuando se ven los cambios en una
línea o qué tanto se mueve en la
dirección vertical en relación con la
dirección horizontal lo que llamamos
pendiente pueden imaginarse la pendiente
de un cerro que tanto hay que escalar
para avanzar hacia adelante pero también
se ven las razones en detalle cuando se
estudia cálculo de hecho las bases del
cálculo diferencial que se estudia en
preparatoria o en los primeros años de
universidad se trata de medir razones o
tasas instantáneas qué tan rápido ocurre
algo en este momento las razones son muy
interesantes e importantes y seguramente
si ustedes se fijan en lo que ocurre en
su vida cotidiana se encontrarán con
muchas tasas o razones